[Music]
good morning folks thanks for taking the
time to join us today for the session we
have a very interesting session today we
have a great panel of experts from you
know cardinal health FTD Palo Alto
joining us today sharing the key
insights that will help you guys you
know think about security for public
cloud and applications that you're
building today so the agenda for the
session would be I'll start with a few
slides fiber so slides just explaining
the key concepts which would be
specially helpful for folks who are new
to public cloud and then we'll
transition quickly into the panel
discussion and I'll invite the panelists
to come join me on stage and we'll have
a Q&A round after the panel is over so
folks in the audience can come up and
ask questions if there are any any
questions you want to ask any of the
panelists so without further delay I
think the key concept that that folks
need to keep in mind as they're moving
into the public cloud is you know
security will be top of the mind and
your security in the public cloud can be
you know same as what you have one prime
it could be better than what you have on
Prem
but the way security will be implemented
in public clouds would be different than
what you are done in public cloud in on
Prem as an example in Google cloud there
are lot of services you could use you
could be using GCE you know gke or you
could be using storage and for example
for GCS and other storage services the
access to do those services is
controlled through api's so when you're
thinking about securing those services
you have to think about what services
what controls what policies you would
have in mind
so people don't have access to the
storage that is being managed by Google
for you there are a couple of key
concepts that you have to think about
when you're thinking about security for
your applications one is how do you
protect from the edge of the network to
close to your workload that's the core
of your network or to that to the
endpoint itself so there will be layers
of security and I'll kind of double
click to explain what the layers are
and the other key concept to think about
is there will be different levels of
security rules you would apply so it'll
start from kind of course rules that
apply to everything and then they'll
move on to more fine-grained rules that
you can apply to control at the micro
service level so as you are kind of
thinking about how do I take care of
security or kind of broadly think about
some of these concepts so just
double-clicking to kind of give you guys
a quick flavor of what this would mean
so for example if you are protecting
your web application you have to think
about you know how do I do
DDoS mitigation or how do I protect my
applications from layer 7 attacks and
you would do that by for example using
the global load balancer we have and the
cloud armor product that was part of the
keynote today and the IEP product as
well so you would use that product you
could have rules layer 3 layer 4 rules
or there seven rules that will protect
the public facing Internet facing
applications you have so that will be
kind of the the protection at the edge
that I spoke about and then you will
bring it closer to your V PC parameter
and think about at your V PC parameter
level what kind of Security's do you
build and how do i lock in access to my
data how do I lock in my access to the
applications and you would do that with
V PC level firewalls this is where you
could have you know rules like you know
I only want HTTP traffic coming in from
the internet so you'll implement those
rules at your V PC level and the example
that I shared about GCS and having
controls and who to access this is you
will do that if we using the V PC
service control so those are kind of the
key concepts you have to think about
when you're protecting your parameter
use the V PC service controls use the
native firewall that we have then taking
it to the next level down you can now
most customers would want to have more
detail more fine-grained controls
controls like you know at your service
account level what your service accounts
can do cannot do what services they can
touch what data they can access so you
would have the next level of security
there you know at gke level at different
I am policy level 2
bring your controls to that level and
all of this you know is greatly
complemented by partner products so they
are native Google products that will
provide you different levels of security
but you should complement them with
partner products that are if you have a
product or system or partner products
and you should think about how partner
products would help you kind of complete
your security story for GCP so I'll just
kind of show you a quick picture on I
will not cover all this can the boxes
here but this is just a quick review for
you to explain how partner products
complement with what Google does so
there's a foundation infrastructure
level that is covered by Google but if
you go above that level into storage
Network you will have you'll add on
partner products to provide
complimentary security services you know
things like pry on products like
next-generation firewalls is something
you know you would work with companies
like Palo Alto Networks and use their
production and their products to
complement the products and services
that Google has to protect you so your
overall security architecture would be a
combination of what we need ibly provide
and partner products that we have so I
think those were the key concepts I
wanted to cover it I think especially
for folks who are new to GCP so they
understand you know how we think about
security how partners come into the
picture and and so on one key concept
that that I wanted to add on before we
call in the panelist was the shared VPC
concept it's a very powerful concept if
you haven't looked at it so far I would
recommend you take a look and just kind
of taking a step back of why this is
powerful
you know the key problem that people had
in public clouds was in every department
every app owner taking your credit card
creating their own projects and there
there will be thousands of projects and
the central security team IT team would
have no control on those projects in
Google that problem was solved using the
organization concept and having a shared
VPC architecture where you would have a
host VPC that your security team your IT
teams who can implement their policies
define the subnets have a next-gen
firewall like Palo Alto in in your hosts
VPC
and have a centralized way of managing
policies for all the the service
projects that your app owners are
creating so your app owners can have the
flexibility of creating the projects
they want they want and without having
to worry about security and and you as
the security admin has the control using
this shared VPC concept by having you
know your security defined at the host
project level and the routing of all the
traffic to the host project having
centralized policies are done you know
in one place and you know then I explain
this concept to you know our partners
key customers they're saying hey this is
the closest we have seen we can get to
the old on-prem centralized control
model so this is a very powerful concept
that helps you do security at scale and
from a centralized fashion so if you
haven't taken a look at the shared VPC
please take a look it also gels very
well with our partner products like the
palo alto vm series firewall and they
plug in beautifully into this shared VPC
model with that i would like to invite
the panelists to join me on the stage so
Rob from Cardinal Health bill FTD and
Sanjay from Palo Alto Networks
to start off I think it'll be great to
start with introductions to folks know
what your roles are in your companies
and then we going well then we'll go and
deeper into you know your journey into
Google flowered and how you thought
about security so Rob if you could go
first with introductions right sorry one
second if you'd like to ask a question
please step to the mics and the aisles
okay yeah I'm Rob Raymond's Cawthon with
the security architecture team at
Cardinal Health we have a great
partnership with our cloud services
cloud engineering team which i think is
very important the reason that we looked
at going to Google and gke is you know
simply speed scalability and obviously
security that's very important to me
bill if you could do your introduction
as well I'm Bill O'Brien from FTD so
it's a gifting company I manage the
network in a telecom group but we work
very closely with security and the cloud
team so we're a pretty small
organization going into the cloud so and
so we have a lot of different hats that
we wear so the more knowledge that we
have for the different areas the better
off we're able to execute Sanjay please
interlinks hey Hank oh good morning
everyone
my name is Sanjay Gupta I'm director of
product management at Palo Alto Networks
for virtualization and cloud security
and as part of the role my team is
responsible for building products right
specifically VM series next-generation
firewall for securing public cloud
infrastructure and networks so I as part
of the role I participate in a lot of
customer discussions and particularly
cloud related advisory boards and for
our councils so really happy to be here
to share some of my perspective
to you guys to help you in your journey
perfect Thank You Sanjay so I'll start
with Rob just kind of trying to
understand you your journey into GCP you
know what made your company decide to be
on GCP and when you were thinking about
security you know how did you think
about security and how did you think
about fallout or being being part of
that answer yeah that was kind of an
easy one Google has always been known
for security ever since Gmail came out
and just the advances since then it made
it pretty easy to look at at Google and
GCP Palo Alto I have about 20 years of
network security experience I've worked
with every different type of firewall
that you can think of over the past 20
years Palo Alto pretty much changed the
game when they came out with the
next-gen firewall so I was very excited
to see that they have a partnership with
Google thank you
so I think build kind of similar
question to you so about your GCP
journey and and how do you think about
security there yeah so from our
organization we had basically a very
monolithic web brand that we have when
we had like six different brands out
there and each one was basically taking
up its own space so they brought in some
new leaders into the organization and
they basically said hey we need to bring
this stuff together right so we had a
initiative to basically take all of
those brands and bring them into the
cloud so he basically had a bake-off
between to Google and another vendor and
Google won out primarily because of the
gke and being able to you know how
Google has that set up to be able to be
managed right because one of the things
is that as being a small company and you
don't want to be experts in everything
right so the things that you can
actually farm off to another company the
better off you're actually going to be
so this way you can actually focus on
the business and actually focusing on
technology so that was one of the the
big drivers and in Palo Alto we already
had Palo Alto in-house and as soon as we
found out because we basically went to
the Google cloud in January
so and we had to have it stood up by
Mother's Day so which was basically by
the end of April
so within four months we basically
decided to go with Google cloud and then
we actually started to roll it out and
as soon as we did that I started talking
with Palo Alto and seeing if they had
actually a beta program and then we
actually got to run out from there and
how was the Mother's Day experience for
you birthing smooth um it was actually
yeah so we actually had Akamai in front
of it so we were actually able to load
how much we're gonna send to the legacy
site and how much we're actually going
to send to GCP so at what point if you
actually put the domain in directly we
actually had a hundred percent of that
traffic going into GCP great to hear
that thank you
and so build one more question for you
just you know double-clicking on what
you have on GCP you know what kind of
workloads do you run and you know how
much are you guys into containers gke
any insights that you can share with the
audience
yeah we're extensively gke so when we
actually first spun it up we wanted to
use shared V pcs but at that time shared
V pcs weren't available on to the GAE
clusters so what we ended up having to
do was we ended up having to create VPNs
within GCP itself to go from the shared
V PC into the GCP into the g ke cluster
but now they've actually brought that in
line and that's one of the biggest
things that we actually saw what Google
was how quickly they're able to move
things from you know alpha to beta to
you know actually having it provisioned
out so and even each day you go on to
the Google console and also and you've
seen like a new pop up and it's just
like hey what is this what is this going
to be doing you know and all sudden then
that's where I'm comes really into a
play because the more people have the
ability to make changes the more
dangerous is going to be so else and as
new features get turned up you want to
be able to make sure that you actually
can colle control the access because
also they're gonna be like hey what is
this button do and also gonna click on
that and then you won't know what
happened so perfect thank you so bill
question for you similarly if you could
double click on what kind of deployment
you have and and what you're using for
gke or any other Rob sir
yet right now we have a lot of non
production workloads out there my two
experts in this space actually three are
in the front two rows here so if we get
to the Q&A I might bring them up to
answer more detail questions but really
it's I would start with non production
obviously get familiar with it
and if you have the DevOps mentality or
methodology make sure that you have very
good ops not just dev so understand
routing networking at the start of it
that'll definitely help you out
thank you it's a quick question for you
you must be talking to a lot of
customers and hearing from them about
how they're moving into cloud any
insights customer stories you have on
where you see customers heading and you
know what are their the key trends their
key challenges that you're seeing sure
thanks me so I mean clearly I think
everyone knows that cloud is definitely
getting more mainstream if not in terms
of real deployments but I definitely see
in terms of interest I containers are
I'd say relatively new or newer right so
so not many customers are I'd say onto
it at this point but but to two main
main perspective I'd like to share right
which which sort of strike me when I
when I when I speak to customers is the
first one is about the difference in
perspective or point of view between the
business and their Caesars so businesses
typically think that the IT and the
security is not moving fast enough while
if you talk to a lot of CEOs and the
security folks they they think that the
business is pulling them in very hard
right so there is this big disconnect
right between the the speed at which the
business wants to move and the speed at
which the security folks want to move
right and I'd say that in a relatively
few successful organizations I've seen
is where the security folks actually
have taken the baton and they
they are essentially moving at the same
speed or even faster than the business
and those organizations I can see are
really you know being very productive
and moving and innovating at a faster
speed the second perspective which I see
is the fact that it's like is the is the
chasm is the chasm between the folks who
have jumped on to the cloud and they
have started their cloud journey
what is the folks who have not right and
in one and and and and one of my
realization has been that hey cloud is
obviously all about speed but it's also
about innovation and being able to adapt
an eye trait right because I'd say like
most cloud providers including Google
itself as bill just mentioned is like
they're coming out with new services at
a phenomenal rate so you should be
willing to both apply security at the at
the right speed as well as willing to -
I trait with these cloud providers and
improve your security controls and
security mechanisms over time perfect
Thank You Sanjay so Sanjay one more
question for you so as customers and in
folks in the audience are thinking about
security
what are your kind of thoughts about
what key things they need to keep in
mind when they're thinking about
security when thinking about moving more
and more workloads into the cloud what
are the key things that you would
recommend them to kind of keep at top of
their list sure so I'll start off I mean
and extend what I was saying before so
the first thing is so I'd say the two
things overall one is speed and second
is new and different at attack surfaces
so as you are moving into cloud and your
applications and workloads into cloud
right you have to realize that cloud is
all about speed so that means that the
security also has to be able to move at
the speed of the cloud and which means
that the security has to get highly
automated like your applications and
workloads are number two the security
has to become more cloud native which
basically means it has to get integrated
into your into your cloud environments
and leveraging the cloud services which
the cloud infrastructure is offering and
that is going to give it that cloud
flavor in the last in this one is the
security fundamentally has to shift left
which basically means security has to
get more ingrained with the app dev
lifecycle like it shouldn't remain
disjointed right from the application
development and deployment itself and
that is why at Palo Alto Networks we we
lay a lot of emphasis on emphasis on
that and there are a lot of product
capabilities and art of including
automation tight integration with Google
cloud as well as making policies more
and more automated is what we invest on
and on the peroxide and then the second
aspect is that that as you are thinking
about the cloud security you have to
realize that there are some things which
have changed in the cloud right which
means that there are some attack
surfaces which have gotten minimized or
gone away right as beneath was showing
the slide earlier right the
infrastructure which is the ownership of
the cloud providers or Google in this
case is gonna be secured by by the
Google themselves but then there are new
attack surfaces which have opened up
which basically means things like pass
services that you're going to consume in
Google Cloud right and you need to think
about how to secure those services right
and that may mean that you will have to
look at new mechanisms and ways
particularly more API centric mechanisms
and ways to secure your environment so
those are the two main points in summary
one is the speed and how you make sure
that your security operates at the speed
of the application and number to be very
aware of the the way the attack surfaces
have changed in this environment and
then how you can secure those new attack
surfaces perfect center that those were
great insights so bill question for you
you know you kind of decided to go down
the gke but what were the key security
aspects or concerns you have to think
about when you decided to go production
and you guys had a limited time frame to
get the security right as you
kind of ramping up a production and for
Mother's Day so can you share some key
insights there
yeah so with gke they primarily went
with gke because of the security that
was already handled within Google so
because they've already had that pretty
much established it was good for them to
be able to use that and for us to be
able to go and move forward with that
so because we had such a short time
window we basically what we did was we
stood up a QA environment for them so we
spun up a QA environment that had a VPN
connection back onto on from so that way
today they could actually start pushing
out their code building their clusters
and start doing a lot of development and
so forth till we actually figured out
what the production environment was
actually going to look like and how big
it actually needed to be in from the the
slide that was up there before with the
the VM series that we ended up spinning
up the Palo Alto and having multiple
interfaces off of it so we had
production we had pre prod we had PCI
and then we basically had kind of like a
services one and then there was a DM
side for a DMZ side as well and on the
DMZ side that was basically where we had
the shared V PC to allow you to connect
back onto on-prem so within the gke it
had roll out with the the controls and
the clusters and everything like that so
it just provided a lot of out-of-the-box
features that just allowed the the
management for us to be spun up very
quickly and then it took a lot of things
off of our plates so that way then we
don't have to worry about OS patches and
things like that and then also it
handles the internal load balancing and
things like that as well perfect thank
you
so Saurabh similar question for you you
know as you guys been implementing you
know how did you think about you know
what products you would use within
Google or you know partner products yeah
I think first the key is having that
partnership with the CISO organization
our vice president spoke yesterday John
latch o and talked about you know take
your sis o out for a few beers or his
favorite beverage beverage repeatedly
keep them on your side that partnership
is critical from the start you don't
want to come in and have to bolt on
security
or be given a stack of requirements
later so really partnered with the
security team so our journey was was
really good because we have this great
partnership at Cardinal Health between
the teams and we found that regularly
meeting weekly stand-ups just working
together really made a huge difference
so as we started looking at cloud native
first you know that's that's always what
we're challenged to do what can you
secure by default within the cloud
provider and then you know if you get
through all those requirements you you
do identify a few gaps or something like
Palo Alto was required primarily ingress
and egress protection from the internet
so in a highly regulated environment
HIPPA gdpr now you have to have those
protections in place but I would urge
everybody in the world look at the cloud
native first stretch it stretch that to
its limits and then start to look at the
third parties perfect so thanks thanks
for that so going back to Sanjay to you
from Palo Alto Networks perspective you
know what are your you know that you
shared a lot of insights are there any
recommendations in terms of as the
customer is going through this cloud
journey on you know how they should
interface with with you and Google any
other recommendations they should keep
in mind on how to go about thinking
about security sure thanks Pete so I
mean fundamentally I think that in many
aspects right going to cloud from a
security perspective is no different
than previously which is that the core
principles of securing or security this
still applies and helices are as
relevant to cloud as they were for any
environment and those core principles
being which we've already believed in is
the fact that a you need to have
complete visibility in terms of what is
going on in their environment be you
need to be able to from that point
onwards be able to minimize your tax
surface which is basically the security
principle of least privilege so that
means that only the necessary activity
whether it's the try
it's user activities transactions is
happening in that environment and then
once you have that as as the as a base
then you manage any known threats in the
environment so you can block them and
control them and prevent them right away
and then on top of that they have the
ability to be able to detect and
remediate any unknown tracks right so
those are the core security principles
that we have been operating on for the
last like 12 years since partners have
been founded and they're and I believe
that they are equally applicable to
cloud to think which is different about
the cloud is is that you know is how do
you apply those security principles and
those security controls in this
environment right which is essentially
about making sure that these things are
can be applied at the speed of the cloud
and these things can be applied across
all attack surfaces like even some of
those new attack surfaces I was talking
about right previously so so
specifically I mean our recommendation
for cloud security is that hey to be
able to achieve that right you need to
look at multiple dimensions of your
cloud deployment which is network
endpoint and the api's so on the network
you should be as Rob was mentioning
right on the network you should be able
to get visibility and be able to control
right your inbound and outbound traffic
into your cloud deployment as well as be
able to segment across multiple
applications or workloads that may be
deployed in the cloud environment what
Anita was talking about the shared we BC
that's a great step forward from Google
which allows you to be able to do that
in a much more effective fashion in
efficient fashion right so with that you
can you can have a good control on who
can access your applications and what
kind of access is happening for those
applications now beyond that on the
endpoint you need to make sure that that
there is no malicious activity happening
and there is no zero to exploits
happening so you need to have mechanisms
so as to be able to control the security
and the endpoint and then lastly it's
about the fact that that as you go more
and more cloud nave you will actually
consume
more and more of cloud native services
which is the the services the great
services that the cloud that the cloud
providers that Google is building into
the environments you use the storage you
would use their yeah their database as a
service right you will use manage gke as
a service and as you do that right you
you may in some sense you know lose
complete visibility in terms of what is
going on and and you need a mechanism
through which you can basically
understand what is going on in this
environment and be able to apply your
and your corporate policies on the data
which is being stored and operated upon
in these environments and and the best
way to do that is a platform like Google
provides a very rich api's and and and
and that is what we have looked at right
and by API is through tools like every
D'Oench we can actually give you that
complete visibility and monitoring on
what is happening in these environments
as well as lets you apply the the
enterprise policies in terms of what is
allowed and what is not allowed and if
anything happens outside the norm
you can utterly mediate so for example
it's like you could say you know what if
any I do not want any workload which is
getting new workload which is getting
deployed in my Google V PC to have
internet access right unless it has been
approved by the policy per se and if
anything set like this happens then
automatically stop and prevent that from
happening or automatically deploy our
next generation firewall in front of the
workload right so that you have complete
control over the ingress and egress
traffic so that is what is what is
important so in summary I believe that
in a cloud deployment the same security
principles apply and you need to look at
it from all the dimensions of network
endpoint and the AP is perfect thank you
and you know completely agree with what
Sanjay said you know we've been working
closely with our partners to make sure
the partner products or you know
integrated and we think about security
in the cloud more in terms of how can we
make security better in the cloud than
what was on Prem how do we make it more
automated I mean everybody knows there
is a kind of a shortage of
security professional so how do we get
ahead of that problem by automating it
more so so it's still early days but
we're working closely with our partners
to kind of make security as seamless as
possible as automated as possible so and
looking forward to it again more and
more innovation together sure I mean and
maybe just to add to that yes we are
definitely working very closely with
Google on that in that direction in
terms of building native integrations
into Google services like stackdriver
Auto scale function building
integrations with gke so you can define
your security policies using kubernetes
label in GAE and we be able to enforce
right without you having to type you
know learn about IP addresses or other
mechanisms of how you apply security
policies so all of that essentially I'd
say are the foundational building blocks
right which allows you to have security
move at the speed of the cloud and be
very seamlessly deployed and operating
in these environments yes thank you so
it's a bill a couple of questions for
you I think you had you know a great
experience deploying something in GAE
you know in the container world gke well
they're kind of new sets of challenges
new kind of securities people have to
think about and also you know companies
in some cases have to rethink how their
teams are organized because things are
kind of moving at a different pace so
any insights on you know what were the
new things that you have to think about
in terms of security challenges in terms
of people organization how teams should
be structured you know would be
especially helpful for folks who are
kind of new into the gke well done what
are the key things that are very unique
because you were on the gk stuff or as
people are moving into the more
containerized world yeah in I think one
of the biggest challenge was that it's
going into the cloud right you you just
don't know what is actually you know
connected to what right you're just
assuming is that hey Google has their
stuff together and be like ok hey how
can we actually make sure this is
actually occurring right and so I was
actually in a presentation yesterday
about compliance right and one of the
things in there was that was to trust
but then to verify right and that was
one of the things of actually going into
GCP was that it's such an unknown thing
that it was just like alright at least
if we could have one common thing that
we actually know right so if we just
like a we're gonna put the Palo Alto
there and we know that everything has to
flow through the Palo Alto so then we
can actually see what the flows are
actually going to occur right so this
way then we can actually trust that but
then as a gke they started to spin
things up and also know it's just like
hey we need connectivity between here
and there and so forth so then we
actually started to build that so a lot
of people who used to be spending time
you know building servers and so forth
are now becoming DevOps managers right
they're working on DevOps to be able to
push things out through that so even
more on the security side where it's
just like okay hey how can we actually
go to like the next level so kind of
like Robert said about the the native
side of it right where it's just like
okay hey we're gonna use the GL B's
right so we already have our fives on
Prem but it's just like right do we
really need you know another set of load
balancers out there where Google already
has you know load balancers kind of like
set up for us to be able to do so we
basically just took this step of like
where do we actually need the tools and
how do we actually get to there so even
going like through the the sessions
yesterday with like M TLS and so forth
where it's just like hey those are going
to be things that worries you're gonna
be looking at and that's the biggest
thing with insecurity is that it's just
gonna be layer upon layer upon layer and
I heard yesterday one of the things was
a really good analogy was that it was a
gentleman from Red Hat who basically had
said I'm sorry it was from Netflix who
basically said you don't want to build
gates but you want to build guardrails
so you want to be able to know where the
traffic is actually going but you don't
want to just put up so many restrictions
that it's just like a it's very you know
cumbersome for the business to be able
to be able to be flexible and be able to
get to where it actually needs to go so
perfect that this goes into yeah
absolutely yeah something that caught my
attention there was trust but verify you
know insecurity you hear that a lot but
I think we're moving more to the zero
trust concept beyond corporate talking
about it Palo Alto has been talking
about it for quite some time
do not trust anything right so every
packet every authentication come at that
with a zero trust mine
but you have to do in this seamless way
like you mentioned bill so you know
don't put gates up where the gates don't
need to be but think about not trusting
everything instead of trusting and
verifying I even get in the habit of
removing that label called trust and
untrust because it gets you in the
mindset that everything coming in that
interface is trusted when it's not so I
just want to make that comment and then
also if you have to change your
architecture to fit a Palo Alto in or in
genetics or another box it's probably a
bad design so you should have a modular
approach where the alb or sorry your GLB
your load balancer works as it's
supposed to work and then you could
insert your security tools in between
that you shouldn't have to change that
and drop similar to what would be
discussed with Bill any kind of
organizational changes or any structural
changes that you're seeing because the
cloud world is different from the
on-prem world or even further in the
container deployments are they different
from what VM deployment used to be yes
the Cardinal health actually has a
dedicated cloud services to him and so
it's almost like everybody's title has
cloud in it now so I think I think it is
important to kind of build that team and
say hey we're gonna do this we're not
just gonna act like a bunch of server
guys trying to manage cloud
infrastructure you really have to get
training education and really go all in
but I think as you build that team make
sure that security and Finance is all
part of that ecosystem from the DevOps
I'm big into calling it dev sac ops
which a lot of people don't like that
but I think eventually it'll just be
called DevOps again once security is
shifted left we have a secure CI CD
pipeline and then I think it'll be
called DevOps again at least from a
security perspective because security is
inherent absolutely I think that's the
vision security being kind of as Sanjay
was saying part of the whole CIC D
pipeline make it as transparent as
possible that people don't even realize
security is there I think that's the
Nirvana State so bill I didn't get a lot
of discussion in the
as well about sto and how sto can help
with security any thoughts about you
know how Wistia would come into the
picture and how it can help folks and
how what you guys are thinking about sto
yeah so we went through one of the
session gesture on this CO and it's it's
very much in line with kubernetes with
how Google has basically set it up is
that it just helps you to do the job of
actually helping the business right it
moves you off of actually having to you
know create you know in-depth reports
and it gets you into M TLS and it gets
you into more security focus so that way
then it's just inherently built into it
right so as they deploy the applications
as they do as they start to pull out the
development that it's actually Auto
ready and integrated into it so that way
then you can set your policies and
controls and it's basically your ready
set so we're looking forward to it
actually
perfect so Sanjay from from a security
company perspective you know where do
you see sto playing a role and what is
Palo Alto thinking about this do and how
to kind of Angele the capabilities that
SEO brings in along with the
capabilities that Palo Alto products
bring in such say I mean I see still as
no different than the fact that hey the
the cloud that the Google cloud platform
by itself provides many of the native
controls built in from a security point
of view like it still is trying to raise
the bar and and do the similar things in
the GTA your kubernetes environment
right so so we we absolutely are looking
to to both integrate and cowork with hto
which is is to is able to provide
certain value in terms of in terms of
base level security in terms of giving
you visibility on what is happening in
your gke and why mate on in general any
kubernetes environment and and we
actively working with the with the gk a
team ended in the hto team to figure out
how how we can insert ng firewall in
these environments and what kind of a
value over and above each tier provides
that we can add and the biggest area
that we believe
is going to be around threat and an
on-site mitigation intact event she
perfect I think the last round of
questions I think I'll start with a Rob
any any comments on sto and in your
concluding kind of remarks any key
lessons learned or key points in
addition to what has been discussed
today that you want to share with the
audience so they can benefit from your
experience yeah is - I'm really excited
about the guys here from Cardinal
probably saw me text them about at least
a hundred times about this to you in the
last few days because I see the security
play how we can do the east and west
segmentation we talked a little bit
about north and south meaning in from
the internet al in and outbound from the
internet but there's also a problem with
East and West security between your
containers between workloads and I think
where sto can bring that security in
between is definitely going to be an
advantage some lesson learns I think go
back to don't change the architecture
based on a security requirement try to
do it transparently you know this is
hard for a lot of security operations
teams that have their favorite endpoint
technology their favorite tool that
doesn't work the same way in the cloud I
would say start to learn other ways to
do things to get the same result just
don't force legacy type tools in the
cloud so that was a lesson learned early
on that we did a little bit of that that
I would urge you to not look at perfect
and robbed it just follow-on question to
that did you think you know in the old
on-prem world you know I had met
companies who would say we have a
hundred twenty security products and
more do you think security looking a
year out our security consolidating or
do you see it still fragmented yeah I
absolutely see it consolidated we're
going through this effort right now we
have so many tools more tools than I
could even name that don't really talk
to each other they're probably not
utilized even twenty percent so I see a
large focus on consolidation getting the
visibility to the security operations
team that they want you know don't NAT
things
time so they have to correlate that so
simplify that so it takes minutes to
troubleshoot but I definitely see a
consolidation of tools thank you so bill
the kind of similar questions and
concluding remarks any key lessons
learned that you can share with the
folks in the audience and your thoughts
of and the consolidation insecurity
where do you see security headed in the
next you know a couple of years yeah I
definitely see security being
consolidated I think everybody's going
to have security basically somewhere in
their title if it used to be you know
DevOps security network security you
know you didn't just you know physical
IT security and everything like that I
want to look more into like the the
Google security command center and see
how that can actually help benefit with
it so in even though you know your your
title might not be is just like hey I
might be a developer I might be you know
an administrator or whatever security is
just such an important part of
everybody's job so and that kind of like
comes a little bit from the military
side of me as well but I think one of
the things for the lessons learned is
Google allows you to be erb the cloud
Google allows you to basically you know
reset your environment so that's one of
the the biggest benefits that I have so
is like especially with ours where was
like a monolithic and we wanted to go to
micro segmentation it basically allowed
us to fix you know known issues within
the network so instead of actually
spending money and you know spending
capex or spending development time of
actually fixing something on from when
you go to the cloud it allows you to
basically reset at that point in time
which is actually extremely beneficial
because the things that we're basically
broken your age should have a chance to
fix things that you actually want to
improve on it gives you a chance to
improve on those items as well so I
think that's one of the big benefits
that we actually go into the cloud
perfect thanks a lot
Sanjay last question for you as well you
know you've been in the security
industry talking to thousands of
customers any key insights on where
security is headed couple of years down
the road and how Palo Alto is thinking
about security as will exist in 2020
sure thanks
so one couple of observations here so
one thing I'd say that clearly I mean
couple of years down the line I mean
today it's gonna be a multi cloud world
right which means you could be in
multiple public clouds and in in your
own time environments as well right so
so I think it is important for you to
think from your security design
architecture perspective that how you
can play in a multi cloud board right
let's say Google is doing a great job
here in terms of you know building
technologies like kubernetes right which
can allow you to be highly portable and
operate in this multi cloud world right
and clearly that is one area where we
are extremely focused on ourselves so
that you so as to have you have you let
you have the flexibility to operate in
this world without the burden of trying
to manage a fragmented set of
environments and managing you know
hundreds of tools which are
purpose-built for specific environments
but it adds tremendous amount of
complexity and are not utilized properly
so so that is one one big area where I
see that things are gonna move and which
is going to be relevant right from from
your point of view the second area where
we see from a security perspective
itself is is that security is gonna be
more and more of a platform play right I
think there is the point which both Rob
and Bill were echoing before in the
sense that that for the security to be
effective you need to be able to
correlate different independent things
together to be able to drive the
necessary outcomes right and and and
best-of-breed
you know point solutions do not play in
that world right so it's gonna be more
and more of a platform play so you
should be looking at tools which can
operate in these heterogeneous
environments and are able to consolidate
multiple security functions together and
then the last point donor's not
necessarily specifically tied to what
you said but I know that you've been
asking Rob and Bill about organizations
per se is that I think in most
enterprises which have been able to
successfully you know
the chasm and move faster into cloud
environments there has to be an auction
which means it cannot be teams operating
in silos in terms of this is the
networking team and this is my security
team and this is my application team the
teams are coming together as a cloud
team right and and in that sense also
there is some kind of consolidation so
to speak of teams which is happening
right and that is very important right
to happen for cloud adoption to be
successful perfect perfect the great
great insights from everybody on the
panel so we had last few minutes for any
kind of questions that anybody from the
audience have there are mics on both
sides happy to take a few questions and
please introduce yourself at the company
that you work for hi my name is the
serum to take away that I got from here
is you can't lift and ship the
applications from your on-prem into the
cloud you have to rebuild it from almost
cloud native services in mind with that
said having tools that are living in the
datacenter would it make sense to try to
reach there the reach into the public
cloud or should we just leave them
behind and not even try to move those
into the public cloud Louis do you wanna
take this one mister lift and shift so
at Cardinal Health we that we've
actually been very successful in moving
our applications as is from on-prem into
the cloud some applications depending on
how they're interacting with the
internet we need to make a few smite
slight modifications to like setting up
global load balancers things like that
but we've migrated hundreds of
applications and non-production we're
beginning our phase of migrating the
production apps as well okay and then
the past these tools are required
network packet visibility is that an
issue is that a thing now
where you're losing the layer one access
to this do you still need that or is
that something that even not even think
about anymore we've actually been able
to using VPC flow logs and firewall
allow and deny logs in google we've been
able to provide our security teams
everything they've been looking for
thank you
go ahead okay hi this is John Skinner
with shape security we provide GCP
hosted AI to prevent account takeover of
login servers and my question is to both
Rob and Bill are there any categories of
data or applications that are deemed
still too sensitive to move into a
public cloud for example in the case of
Cardinal HIPAA regulated patient health
records of perhaps the patient login
that sits in front of it or in the case
of FTD is your whole ecommerce platform
and the customer login sitting in front
of it in the public cloud and if not why
not
for us it's obviously pH I and HIPAA but
also gdpr and I'd say absolutely not we
can make them much more secure in the
cloud
in minutes versus like months and years
to do that same type of micro
segmentation so that's that's my answer
yeah for credit card information and
also for customer information yes we're
gonna be migrating up into the cloud so
it's not there yet but our plan is to do
there but we're gonna have additional
security around it okay thank you thank
you and then after that you can discuss
in private
thank you sorry just one last comment I
think after the session will be here so
we can take questions you know after the
session as well please okay I'm Ian them
I'm the CEO of the Irvine Company and uh
I wanted to follow up a little bit on
that question you know there there's a
lot of discussion in kind of the GDP our
world and how you know Google and Amazon
Facebook have the ability from a cloud
platform perspective to do bi on the
back of the data right and I know that
that's on the consumer side not on the
enterprise side but but nonetheless
right you spoke a little bit about me
you spoke a little bit about visibility
are there any any assurances that we
have that you know below the line of
what we can control that Google you know
has no you know access or bi to to our
data you know especially the PII stuff
the healthcare stuff so absolutely and
this was a
that we have heard from from customers
as well other customers so there's a lot
of work done on access transparency so
things like every time if you go eyes
call customer support for Google and
customer support goes and looks at
anything in your organization any action
they take any page they visit will be
logged so there is you know look at that
I think that is you know a lot of work
has been done to make sure customers
feel very comfortable from nobody from
Google is looking into your data anytime
if they look into the data because you
called in to support anything they did
would be logged and you would have
visibility and you can see it almost
real-time that what they're doing
absolutely absolutely absolutely
absolutely thank you okay thanks a lot
and thanks a lot for the panelists I
think that amazing insights and thanks a
lot to Palo Alto Networks for helping to
make this session possible thank you for
coming cube
[Music]